Arguably, one of the most attractive features of
FHIR for developers is its composibility.
Each FHIR resource is an independent object and can
be retrieved as needed using our appropriate FHIR API query.
This is distinctly different from earlier standards, such as CCDA,
where an entire clinical document must be
retrieved even though only a specific part of that document,
such as a patient's problem list, is of interest.
FHIRPath is a path-based navigation and extraction language, something like XPath.
XPath can be used to navigate through elements and attributes in an XML document.
FHIRPath does the same thing for FHIR.
For example, a simple FHIRPath script can navigate through and
retrieve specific sub-elements of a large FHIR bundle,
such as an entire patient record.
In other words, FHIRPath further extends
composibility to individual data types or even their values so
resources can be mined to more efficiently supported development
of specific capabilities in a FHIR app or for other purposes.
The technical details are available online,
but we can easily see how useful this could be through some examples.
To do that, we'll take advantage of David Hay's wonderful web tool, clinFHIR.
Using clinFHIR, as you can see here,
we create a new patient record based on
demographic data from the CCD of Josephine Vazquez,
a synthetic patient available to students in this course.
One of clinFHIR's many attractive features is the generation of
some sample data so that our new patient
begins with a reasonable facsimile of a medical record.
We've checked the generate samples box here to do that.
ClinFHIR indexes the resulting 72 FHIR resources by type,
as you can see here on the left.
The single patient resource has been selected and its contents are
displayed in a human-friendly tree view here on the right.
Note that the patient resource has been assigned the ID 299014.
A number that you know by now can be used to easily retrieve this resource or,
depending on the capabilities of an individual FHIR server,
just specify the other resources such as medications or
clinical observations are to be retrieved but only for this patient.
Of course, computer software would deal with this resource in XML or JSON.
It should be easy to see that the same data,
shown in the tree view on the right,
is also in the JSON on the left.
ClinFHIR's FHIRPath Expiration Tool makes it easy
to create a bundle containing our patients entire record,
as shown in the middle here.
This may be a simplistic representation of
a patient record but displayed in Microsoft Word,
this bundle occupies 96 pages and is 5401 words long.
We already know that we can use the FHIR API to retrieve a specified part of the bundle,
such as only the condition resources.
But suppose that we really only want to display the patient's medical problems,
that information is contained in those conditioned resources,
and it would certainly be passed through write some code to parse that out of them.
However, FHIRPath makes that much simpler,
as shown in the right of this graphic.
As you can see here, this script,
when run using clinFHIR's server side implementation of
the FHIRPath interpreter developed by Josh Mandel and Nikolai Russakoff,
produces exactly the text needed to display the patient's medical problems.
To give another example,
a FHIRPath's script could use the appropriate Lloyd code of
8867-4 to produce a list of the patient's heart rate measurements,
as shown just below the box where
the FHIRPath script that produced the list would be typed in.
I've intentionally obscured most of the script should you try writing it.
Capabilities such as these make app creation far easier and faster,
leading to more rapid innovation and more usable software tools.
For example, starting with this list of heart rate values,
it is a simple matter to create a graph of
Josephine's heart rate over time, as shown here.
If you think back to our discussion of VHRs,
you may remember that not all of them can do something as simple as produce this graph.